[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000.
it's an exciting day for chess as jan
napong nashi
is officially the 2020 and 2021
candidates champion won both years in
one tournament
very impressive stuff but tonight i
wanted to walk you through some of the
most exciting and some of the most
instructive games from the back half of
the tournament
of course there was that long break in
the middle due to the pandemic
but they finally wrapped it up and so
first and foremost i wanted to go over
one of the first games from the restart
which was the game between
fabiano caruana and maxime vashir legrov
so of course fabi had the white pieces
and coming into
the restart of the tournament was a full
point back
behind joint leaders nvl and yan
so let's see what fabi was able to do
against mvl
at that time the leader of the
tournament we had e4
and mvl of course no surprises here
is going to play the najdorf and this
has long been
a point of discussion for fans of mvl
and fans of the nydorf
is playing the nydorf every game
or nearly every game of course he has
mixed it up from time to time
nearly every game you have the black
pieces really a viable strategy
at the top level and in this game fabi
perhaps
was out to prove that you cannot really
get away
with being quite so predictable at the
top level
the night earth is just so complex with
so many nuances and so many
uh ways for white to divert the game
that's uh perhaps you are setting
yourself up for a little bit of
an opening preparation trap uh if you
are going to play this opening
every single time that being said though
fabi had a year
to prepare an opening line against mvl
of course he spent a lot of that year
looking
at the najdorf looking at his options
and what he comes up with
is the bishop g5 line and no surprises
here this has long
been known as one of the most
complicated one of the most heavily
theoretical lines in the najdorf bishop
g5 really does put a lot of pressure on
to black and the reason for that is you
cannot really get away with the typical
night or if idea of playing e5
in response to bishop g5 why not
well as usual in the night or if e5 is
only really a bad move
on move six if white is allowed to play
this nice idea of knight f5 and that is
going to be the case here knight f5 is
simply quite strong
pressuring this pawn and if you are to
if you were to capture
the problem now for black is that you
cannot play the move d5
because we've so cleverly placed our
bishop here on g5 just
a little background on the knight for
you and this is why black generally
plays this move e6 in the main variation
fabi continues with the normal idea of
f4 now
preparing uh joint ideas of e5 breaking
in the center with this pawn
or in some cases the idea of f5 to
challenge the e6 pawn
now in my night or series i actually
recommended the
h6 variation here that mvl himself has
pioneered quite a bit
uh and going for the delayed poison pawn
so the poison
pawn is what mvl goes for in this game
with queen to b6
in my night of series i actually
recommended h6 first
drawing this bishop back to the
potentially weak h4 square
and following that up with queen b6 but
we'll see that mvl is actually going to
transpose here in just a minute so we
start with queen b6 in this case uh
white
in this case does play queen to d2
allowing black to capture
the quote-unquote poisoned pawn of
course a3 is a common way to decline
in the delayed version and in this case
knight b3 is perfectly reasonable as
well
of course for those that aren't aware
very common trap here
with taking the b pawn is a3 controls
the b4 square
and this queen can be left without a
retreat
so in this case though queen d2 allowing
black to capture we get queen b2
rook b1 solving the problem of the rook
with tempo
queen to e uh queen to a3 and now fabi
continues
with uh more or less the main idea in
the position
in my series i spent a lot of time
talking about f5 and i spent quite a bit
of time talking about e5
and in this case we see that fabi is
adopting
the method of playing pawn to e5
and now is where our repertoire becomes
relevant for those of you who did watch
the whole series
ah mvl here plays h6 and after bishop h4
we've actually transposed directly to a
line that i recommended
so i was quaking in my boots uh
as i saw mvl play the lines that i
recommended
um of course he's the one who kind of
came up with most of these lines in the
first
place um but i was like this is not so
good for my narrative repertoire
uh favi is coming up with something here
so h6 bishop h4 played in the game
of course something like e takes f6
isn't quite
right in this instant instance because
this just simply isn't very good black
has taken over the center
and hasn't given up too much in exchange
so we see bishop h4 and now d takes e5
opening up the d file and more
importantly opening up this diagonal for
black's bishop
we get f takes e5 knight f to d7
is one of the main ideas uh g5 is
actually a bit more common
but i was not such a fan of this
variation and as such i actually did
recommend knight ftd7
as played in the game uh now we get
knight to e4
still the main line stuff from fobby you
need to walk or
step out of nasty bishop b4 ideas by
simply defending this square and
allowing this pawn's mobility
uh mvl continues with the only playable
move here for black
which is grabbing another pawn on a2 and
the idea isn't so much that you're
grabbing a pawn
that part is nice but it's more so that
you need to be able
to bring this queen back to d5 in order
to defend against threats down this file
so we see rook to d1 increasing the
pressure queen to d5
and here queen to e3
trying to dodge any kind of queen trade
and uh
you know of course supporting this
knight in the center as
well we continue down the main variation
with queen takes e5
i really wasn't joking when i said that
this line was uh heavily theoretical
and this is where fabi breaks
the mold so those of you watching who in
the chat
can tell me foggy's great novelty and of
course what is the
actual main line here who saw it
who saw it happen
did anyone in the chat see this game
live
so let's start with the main move while
the chat thinks of you know fabi's
brilliant novelty
the main move here uh has been
historically this move bishop
to e2 and that's not uh hard to
understand right you bring the bishop
off of the back row you prepared a
castle and actually we're going to see
this bishop land on h5
in many of the main variations and you
can continue down
um my quote-unquote night or repertoire
that i recommended
with bishop to c5 here and the point
being
we are just getting rid of some of these
nasty pieces
uh standing in the center of the board
and we're going to try to get our king
castled with black
this line continues with bishop g3
i recommended the move queen to d5 here
and now
uh it's not such an uncommon idea to try
and take over the d5 square
with the move pawn to c4 and we're going
to see this idea potentially crop up a
little bit later on
and what i said basically in my
neighborhood video is we're going to
take on d4
we'll see rick takes d4 and a queen
check to move out of the way
white more or less has to play this move
rook to d
rook to d2 otherwise black is just going
to castle and be
quite significantly better so rook to d2
and castles and now the point of white's
play
is that this bishop can land on this
nice d6 square
and sooner or later uh black is going to
to have to give up the exchange it might
not be entirely obvious why
right now but this rook is more or less
dead and the play continues here i
recommended the main move of
f5 we see bishop f8 knight f8
knight d6 and my recommendations here
went on for just a few more moves
basically ego knight bd7
and what i had to say uh in my knighter
video
was that black is doing perfectly fine
here
if and it's a big if you can get the
queens off the board
the good news for black is that there's
no real way
to keep the queens on the board if
you're playing with the white pieces
here
if you castle it's quite easy we're
playing queen c5
and mvl himself has a game in this
position
and if you play some kind of waiting
move or even some kind of crazy g4
move we're not going to wait too long
before we get the queens off the board
with the nice idea of queen a one check
and queen e5 once again pinning the
queen to the king
and there's just no way to prevent the
queen trade so
keeping that main line uh in mind here
we now arrive at fabi's novelty with the
move
pawn to c3 and this looks like a pretty
deep
idea at first but it turns out that this
is quite the useful move
for white it's sort of anticipating the
bishop c5 idea
it defends the knight on d4 and perhaps
even more importantly
it preemptively has stopped queen a5
from being a check which means if we
were to find some way to harass this
queen on d5
there wouldn't be really a comfortable
way to
sort of escape this threat and that
brings us to the game line mvl saw this
move of c3
and decided it's not such a big deal
right white is still
two moves away from castling here so
there's no real reason to deviate too
much with the black pieces
we're still gonna play bishop c5 we're
still going to get our king castled
and we're still going to be better
unless white can prove something
quite quickly and i'm not sure what this
lower third is on the screen with the
historic world championships
okay we're adjusting but the bishop now
on c5
and the problem here for mvl isn't
necessarily
his position on the board his position
on the board is still
fine his problem is that he played the
night or
and his opponent played a novelty now
why is this such a big deal
well when you are uh over the board
and your opponent plays a novelty in the
night or you don't have this nice little
thing over here
that says hey you're still fine white
has to walk a pretty tight rope
to maintain the balance you have to
think in your head oh my god
is fobby about to refute the night or in
you know the year 2021
and what comes with that is severe time
time issues time pressure and that's
what uh mvl ran into in this game he
spent
i think nearly an hour uh probably more
than an hour now that i'm thinking on it
on the next few moves bishop c5 included
fabi of course had it all prepped and
immediately played bishop g3
the only real move to continue the game
um
now queen to d5 and fabi hits mvl
with a a real stunner here so
as chess king in the chat mentioned uh
there is a pretty shocking move that
fabi
pulled out after queen to d5
there are uh there is another way that
white can play here
there's a very interesting idea of
playing this move bishop to d6
with the idea being we're going to make
use of this rook on d1
if this bishop were to move out of the
way black must continue with bishop
takes d6
and now there's an interesting idea of
knight b5
and all seems to be going wrong for
black
if not for black's next idea here black
is actually
essentially forced to give up this queen
for the rook
and capture this knight and after knight
d6
king e7 knight takes b5 for example
it turns out the black is is actually
doing quite all right here
uh even though the black is in fact down
a queen the reason for that being
this rook on a8 is going to be very very
useful in hindering
white's development it's going to be
very tough to complete the development
of white's pieces here
and black is doing fine but fabi found
the trickier way which is of course
the stunning bishop c4
black really just can't move out of the
way for this one
then it would just be a free developing
move for white
and what are you gonna do lose a tempo
in the night or are you
crazy are you insane you're gonna get
killed
knight d6 check and this king is going
nowhere and black's gonna die in like
five moves
so mvl says okay i'll take a piece uh
fabian continues now with bishop d6
the only real idea you need to keep the
king stuck in the center in order to
have some counter play here
and to his credit mvl finds literally
the best line
the problem is with having such a
predictable repertoire
even if you can think your way out of it
in an opening like the najdorf
you're just gonna get murdered on the
clock and
that happened in this game uh mvl does
find knight f6
and after knight takes c5 giving the
piece back
it turns out this is the best way to
continue uh we do see knight d5
queen e5 and now still the best move
rook g8
and then fabi just keeps coming with the
hits knight d
takes e6 um you know what's one
piece sacrifice good for if you've
already gotten your material back
you got to sacrifice more and that's
exactly what fabi does here you need to
rip open
the king's position and keep the tactics
flowing
or else you're just going to find
yourself
down quite a few pawns for example if
you were to play some kind of bad move
here like knight e4
just kind of backing off and defending
your weaknesses here
white is simply losing after knight to
d7 black is just
up one two three pawns
and if black is up three pawns and not
getting checkmated
black's doing pretty well so knight
takes e6 keeping the hits coming f takes
e6 knight e6
queen c3 check queen c3 and knight c3
and this is why black is not totally out
of the game yet in order for fabi to
keep the attack
coming black uh was able to get the
queens off the board
that's the danger of leaving the king in
the center and that's why
mvl is so great at night or just as in
the other line
black is only able to survive with the
assurance of a queen trade
even though it took him quite a while to
find the ideas over the board
who can really blame him in the game
though we continue with knight c7 check
black brings the king out to f7
now we see rook to d3 the accurate idea
by fabi of course it would be a mistake
to take on 8 and allow
black to capture on d1 when i think
you're simply
just going to be down two pawns for
nothing so rook d3 instead
and now mvl unfortunately finally starts
to let it slip
it appears that mvl sort of navigated
all of the trials
of this game so far in the opening of
course he used a lot of time to do so
and perhaps in that time pressure he
started to make some inaccuracies here
so it turns out the best way for black
to play
is the rather stubborn and even stupid
looking move rook to a7 i think this is
a perfectly good way to not be any worse
at all
with black for those of you who are
worried about your najdorf repertoires
just play all of these moves and then
play rook a7 and you'll be fine
um why is rook a7 so good
well after white must take back on
c3 we have even material with two extra
pawns
for black of course black has yet to get
developed though
by the way white could throw in a check
here but that is not the most critical
um it doesn't change the position much
but
black still needs to get developed is
what i'm trying to say
and black is going to have to sacrifice
one or both of these pawns in order to
achieve that goal so for example
if we play something like knight to d7
here something like knight d5
uh or even bishop b6 sorry so knight d7
would stop
bishop c5 but if we were to play
something like king g6 stepping out of
castles with check
white can throw in bishop to c5 but
black has this nice idea
of not losing the rook by giving up one
of the pawns that's just something i
wanted to highlight
but knight d7 does stop that in fact so
after knight d5
something like knight f6 and white
really has to play
quite accurately here accurately here
with knight e7
and knight takes g8 giving up the
exchange
but now uh black is perfectly uh
positioned
to hold this um it's actually better
to take white's knight off the board in
exchange
for the piece then allow white to have
this knight on the board
why is that well with this light squared
bishop versus this dark squared bishop
black is able to just kind of plant this
piece onto c6
and never really worry about the
weaknesses
of the pawns complicated stuff still to
be sure
in the game though mvl plays knight to
e4 and this is the beginning
of fabi building an advantage white
castles with check we see king to g6
and now fabi gets to take the rook under
slightly more favorable circumstances
because it's a little bit more difficult
to get developed with black here
and now mvl makes the second mistake
that sort of
locks him into a long end game of
suffering
so black to move here see if you guys
can find a nice
setup straight out of development that
would have allowed mvl
to try and hold just a little bit more
easily
see what you guys can come up with
what can you come up with here how do we
get our pieces out with black here
we are down the exchange but not all
hope is lost because we do
have these two queen side pawns
chess king says bishop f5 to start
interesting idea
so try and imagine your ideal setup with
black you want to try and come up with
something
that looks like it's going to be a
really tough nut to crack because to win
here with white
you quite simply have to attack some of
black's weaknesses
so let's identify what those are uh
weakness number one
is going to be these queen side pawns b7
especially
and if b7 is forced to move then a6
and on the king's side we're going to
have to worry about the g7
pawn as well so keep those in mind
keep those in mind
so dronis actually has the correct idea
here
although he has the incorrect notation
so bishop d7 to c6
i think is the most human and best way
to uh sort of defend this position you
start with bishop d7
and the good news here is that you have
some tactics that prevent you from
losing the game immediately so
points to you if you discounted bishop
d7 because it hangs
a piece but points even more points to
you
if you noticed that bishop b5 is a
tactic that is actually going to leave
black on the better side of this end
game
after bishop takes b8 for example rook
e3 looks like it's attacking a lot of
pieces
but at the end of the day
um your knight on a8 is going to be
hanging as well and black would actually
be winning if we followed all the way
through to the end of this
um sort of desperado line so bishop d7
is playable
but does that make it good it turns out
it does make it a pretty good idea
in my opinion after knight c7 we're
gonna put this bishop on c6
and we're a lot closer to just gluing
our position together
with this organization of the black
pieces than the one we're gonna see
in the game so this is what i would have
liked to see
from mvl chess bunzo actually
recommended an interesting idea
with rook to d8 this was actually the
engine's
top suggestion at first but the further
i followed down the line
sort of the less i liked it and actually
kind of the less the engine like
all right i do see myself okay hello
hello everyone
um we're back brief technical snafu
there i'm talking about this rook on d8
what a chess move um so as i said the
engine tends to like this move
but uh the further and further you go
down the line it does turn out to still
have some difficulties
for black and i was saying that's
because it's not very intuitive
necessarily to trade off one of these
rooks because when you're down the
exchange
the two rooks for white can end up being
superfluous
so imagine a pure endgame where the only
pieces left on the board
are the two rooks for white a rook for
black and a light squared bishop
if black puts the light squared bishop
on c6 white is never going to be able to
threaten these queenside pawns
right the rooks just can't do it because
they would have to sacrifice themselves
for black's bishop so these rooks
can sometimes just get in each other's
way in the meantime
black is able to use the rook to defend
and even create threats on the other
side of the board
but in this specific instance it might
be beneficial to trade off one of the
rooks because white's winning plan
sort of necessarily involves getting
these rooks to the seventh
and going after these backwards pawns
and
if black can prevent both rooks from
getting to the seventh by trading one of
them off
it might be a worthwhile endeavor and
why am i talking about trading rooks
well that's the natural end result of
this rook on d8 uh rook f to d1
is going to be white's move then after
you get developed
white's gonna play bishop to a3 and at
this point you really do
need to trade these guys off if you try
and keep this guy on the board
it's just going to get pushed around and
not have very many places to go
while white strokes are going to be
threatening to invade at any moment
uh so rook d8 interesting move but
bishop d7 this setup i recommend instead
mvl chose option c with knight to c6
and the problem with this is that this
bishop does end up being a little bit
awkward and fabi is able to use this to
his advantage
uh knight b6 challenges this bishop and
after rook to d8
we see the bishop come off the board and
now
there's just no sort of glue like we
would have with the bishop on c6
there's no glue holding these pawns
together and we'll see that fabi does
end up
tearing them apart heartlessly
but as time is short we've already spent
a half hour on this game i want to jump
to the interesting end game
fabi works his magic and wins the queen
slide pawns
don't worry about it makes a weakness on
this side of the board as well
and we end up in this
particular position here rook takes a6
and we have this interesting end game
and this one went on for quite some time
as you see on your screen fabi ended up
winning it but i thought it was
worthwhile to
sort of mention the drawing plan that
mvl
missed and the winning plan that fabi
uh enacted so uh let's fast forward just
a couple moves we see
knight f7 and king e4 so
first and foremost i want to ask you
guys what the
winning plan for white should be here
try and imagine a position where white
is winning
and see how you can accomplish that so
try and uh try and come up with that
first and then we'll work
on finding a drawing idea for black
new book chess glue not a bad idea not a
bad idea
trade rook for night uh not necessarily
but if you can trade the work for the
night and win black's pawn
and have a winning king and pawn end
game position at the end of it
then you might be correct
so of course the k the key here is
to use white's king as uh as it is in
many of these pure end games
king becomes very very important when
there are very very few pieces on the
board
so of course the rook alone is not going
to be enough to shake loose
you know the king and the knight working
together right there's no way you just
win one of these pieces or the pawn
with the king and the knight working
against the rook so you need white's
king
involved somehow but what does that
actually look like how do you get the
king involved
well running around to this way is
actually going to be a potential option
for
white but this is going to come with a
pretty substantial risk
and that risk is going to be black's
main drawing
mechanism which is if this king gets a
little bit too crazy
then black is going to go after this
pawn on g2 and of course if white loses
this pawn
rook versus knight is just a dead
dead draw i wouldn't say it's unlosable
but it is very very difficult to to win
and it is objectively a draw
so we need some better method of
activating the king
and that's how you arrive at the winning
plan in the game
of bringing the king around this side
you want the king on this side of the
pawn so that
yes it is attacking black's pawn but
also
it's preventing black from getting too
crafty
and going after the pawn on g2 this king
is close enough by
where if the pawn is starts to get
attacked
it can help out in that regard at the
same time kind of box out black's king
and so let's see what that looks like
right fab is going to try to get the
king to h5
and we'll see in a couple moves what mvl
is
able to do to try to stop it for the
moment we get some shuffling
and now i want to ask you how can you
prevent this king
from ever touching the h5 square
and coming after your pawn
no points to you if you've already seen
the
the game
i am seeing this chat neil i am seeing
it
neil said why not take knight when rook
g8 and i chose not to respond to that
message
because i didn't understand what it
meant but if neil wants to rephrase
i may just respond
um and yeah everybody everybody clearly
knows the idea
everybody clearly came up with this
independently
mvl's just a dummy who didn't see the
drawing idea so
with this information in mind we first
found white's winning plan
and now all we need to do with black is
prevent it
and it turns out the best way to do that
is sort of the simple way here we just
defend
the h5 square with our knight and build
a glorious blockade
by playing knight f5 and after white's
move of rook d3
we bring the knight to g7 and this now
is going to be a draw we built our big
fortress here and this is going to be
impenetrable
by white's king now you might notice
there's a hole
in the fortress on the e7 square and
that's why i threw in this caveat of the
king
can't really get too too active by
running all the way back around to the
f8 square because then
black is going to have the very very
simple idea of using the knight and the
king
to force the win of the pawn on g2 the
knight and the king together
if white's king is all the way back on
e7 or f8
uh these two pieces are going to be able
to win this pawn against the rook it's
just two versus one
easy math uh and so this knight on g7
turns out to just be a very very simple
fortress
that just cannot be broken no matter how
hard you try
black is going to shuffle like this or
like this or like this
the king is sort of only around to hold
everything together
and make sure that this pawn on f6
doesn't get lost
but in the game mvl plays the fateful
knight to h6
and we'll see now that fobby misses the
winning idea
at first but we'll go back to the
position where
it's once again winning and we'll see
what idea fabi has in mind so we get
knight to g8 here
now how can we win
uh mvl has not been able to get the
knight to g7
and white now has a winning idea
winning idea and this one is pretty deep
pretty deep
rook takes knight not quite you got to
calculate first gotta calculate
ray says it's intuitive in capturing
pieces is intuitive but of course this
is
a pretty simple draw
black just shuffles if you go this way
black goes this way
so that king and pawn end game not good
enough
so this one i'm not gonna lie to you
it's a little bit too hard
even for people who've already seen the
answer so the idea is pretty deep here
um basically you need to put black
into zugsvang which is easier said than
done
in this position so how do we put black
into xbong well fabio starts with
rook to h3 now if black were to play a
move like knight to e7
we could see the nice move rook h7 check
and the idea now
is that after something like even g3
here
perhaps more simply something like king
to f4
there's no way black can stop us from
getting to h5
if you play something like knight f5
trying to set up your fortress
of course it's a little bit too late now
because we already control this square
king g4 actually would run into knight
e3 check but you can play something like
g3 first
and still be quite easily winning um
knight d6 for example and we can go this
way
if we need to sorry just being being a
little bit cautious
with what i say to make sure i'm not
blowing it so 97 not a good pass king g6
is the other way to pass
but now incredibly we are going to waste
a
second tempo with the move rook to b3 or
a3 or c3 i don't think it matters
now if we play the move king to f7
um king to f4 is finally
the zugswang and actually so this is
what happened in the game king g6 and
then
rook to a3 and now if knight to e7 for
example
there is the stunning rook to a5 again
zugsvang keeping the knight out of f5
very importantly
to keep the knight from getting to g7
instead in the game
we see king f7 by mvl and now after king
f4
the zug's funk has actually been
achieved sort of out of nowhere
so two waiting moves by white were
required
to get the zug um with subtle
differences each time the rook being on
h3 allowed this work h7 idea
and now after king g6 or k3 we have this
rook a5
idea to meet knight e7 and now
what's the problem well the problem is
if you play king g6
you're going to get checked
and you can't stop me from getting to h5
if you play knight e7 you're gonna get
pinned
king e6 and once again you can't stop me
from getting to h5
and if you play mvl's move of king to f7
after king f4 you are in fact in
zugzwang believe it or not if knight is
seven
again you get pinned and we've seen this
before
and if knight to h6 this is what was
played in the game
there is the astonishing move rook to g3
what's the point the point is you can't
play any moves
with black here you can't go knight f5
for obvious reasons
you can't bring the king to the g file
to shuffle and
if you were to um
[Music]
sorry play the move knight to g8 the
winning idea now is to use
the preemptive discovered check and
attack on the knight
with the move king to g4 black has to go
king g6 to try to stop you from getting
in
now after king to h4 the king cannot
defend both the knight and the h5 square
at the same time
uh king to f7 king h5 would come
and white is winning the king is
invading and the f6 pawn will fall
we got a slightly different version of
this in the game after king g4 mvl
didn't even try
to stop the king with king to g6
instead playing 97 and now fabi invades
with king to h5
and the game only lasts a couple more
moves the king
gets into g6 and after king g6
mvl went ahead and resigned there's
simply no good way
to keep this pawn defended knight f4
check isn't that with king f7
and once again it's an unfortunate zug
for
black no way to defend this guy if you
go knight d5
uh even rook takes f6 here is good
enough
with the pawn becoming a queen so really
great game by
fabi um it was a fantastic way to start
off
uh the back half of the tournament of
course though he
faltered a little bit later on i don't
think we have time to look at that game
though because
we're already down to like 20 more
minutes that game
ate up a lot of time it was quite
complicated so now i want to
talk about a game between wang hao and
yan napomnishi so this was in round 12
or yeah around 12 i believe and it's
pretty much the last win yan scored and
it kind of uh secured the victory for
him
uh and of course after this tournament
wong hao has now
announced his retirement which is sad
news for
the chess world i love watching wang hao
play and he actually gave one of my
favorite interviews of all time
and maybe this interview is going to
provide a little insight
as to what wong hao will be getting up
to after
he his retirement from chess and i
believe we have a short clip of it
if all went well i don't know
if you wouldn't have been a chess player
what would have you been
i would like to be some wizard
[Laughter]
that infectious laugh by wong house so
he is going to become some wizard but
he could not wizard his way out of the
grip
of yon napomnishi and that's what we're
going to look at to wrap up today's
class
uh it's my favorite interview question
and answer of all time
um okay wong with the white pieces
though against yon
so at this point jan was in seoul first
place and wang hao was perhaps trying to
play a little bit of a spoiler
in the event um if he could defeat yan
that would blow the tournament wide open
but yan came in clutch when he had to we
see
e4 e5 knight f3 knight f6
and we're going to blow by the opening
pretty quickly it was a
petrov and a very very symmetrical line
both sides
occupying the center after the e pawns
were
taken we get bishop d3 bishop d6 again
very very symmetrical
and wong hao actually goes ahead and
trades off the queens
so now black gets to say the queens are
off the board
we have a symmetrical structure i
shouldn't really be any worse
even though my king is in the center and
white is going to try to say yeah
but i get to castle my rook is coming in
the game quite quickly and your king is
maybe a little bit
misplaced on the e7 square
um generally here the main move is the
pretty natural idea of rook to e8
but then this would be met with rookie
one check and rook takes e8
and there are actually quite a few games
here at the top level
magnus played it back in 2017 against st
louis's own var ocobian
and magnus actually won that game with
white and there's also another game
by entie etienne beckrow that was also
one of the white pieces so it looks
pretty dead here
but it does turn out there are some
ideas of
play especially with this move knight c3
this is going to be the move that breaks
the cemetery
because it's just not effective anymore
to continue
copying white bishop g5 is going to be a
little bit too strong
with threats to the d5 square
so black would have to play c6 and you
know uh
2800 level stuff 29 almost 2900 level
for magnus carlsen
you beat your opponent you have like an
extra tempo and more active pieces
so how does jan get around this well yan
plays the move knight to c6
and the reason why i bring sort of the
this other line up
is i want to stress this isn't really
wang hao playing for a draw here there
are
some decisive games from this point even
though it is so symmetrical
um and after knight c6 wong how actually
deviates
from the main theory rookie one check
tends to be what players with the white
pieces played
but instead we actually see wang hao
play c3
and unfortunately this is sort of
turning into
that line we just looked at except with
colors reversed black was the first to
develop the piece
and white now has to respond with c3 as
opposed to knight c3
and pawn to c6 and i think with this
simple
simple uh you know sort of switcheroo
here black is actually going to end up
being a little bit
positionally better thanks to the
activity of this
knight we see h6 played in the game
and this is a little bit of a strange
one to me i'm not so sure that this was
strictly necessary but yan was perhaps
anticipating
a bishop g5 with some idea of doubling
black's king aside pawns
as this does show up in the main line so
we get knight h4 now by wang hao
rookie 8 getting developed knight f5
bishop f5 bishop f5
king f8 we get g3 97
bishop h3 knight back to c8 and
knight c3 so some subtle maneuvering by
both players here i'm going to fast
forward a bit
as we see both players adopt this
structure
and white now with the two bishops is
playing against
black's knights now the problem though
is that these knights
are in fact going to have quite good
squares and in the meantime
these bishops are sort of effectively
being handled
we see knight b6 threatening to jump
into c4 a very active square
and that leads to white playing this
ever so slightly weakening move
of b3 i do think though that this
is not such a great idea for
white it sort of had to be done to deal
with this knight coming to c4
you can allow this knight to sort of
just sit there
but i think speaking from a human
perspective it's
you're not very happy with your position
if the knight can just stay on c4 kind
of indefinitely
and b3 is eventually going to come
we do see it right away though by wong
hao now we get king g7 king f2
and black reroutes this knight as its
job is done threatening to come to c4
and this knight actually lands on e6 and
again
we see these bishops being very
effectively handled right the diagonals
are remaining closed or empty in the
case of this
bishop and the bishops just don't really
have many squares on such
a tightly knit board the bishop steps
back to e3
and quite clearly this is not the best
piece in the world
rook to c8 now by jan is a slightly
strange idea
but after bishop d2 he's actually being
the one who's breaking through
with the black pieces here with c5 and
you know some people might say in some
games yan had shown a tendency to lean
towards
draws when possible in this back half
trying to preserve his lead
but i think this sort of effectively
shows you know he's he's here to win the
game right he's the one who's breaking
first he's trying to score points
in many of these positions we get dc5
bishop c5
king g2 and now bishop back to b6 and
with these changes we see black with a
very nice solid
setup all the pieces defended aside from
this bishop on b6
and after rook b1 uh black even fixes
that
and in the meantime white's position is
pretty solid as well
but you already see the long lasting
effects of moving the pawn from b2 to b3
this pawn on c3 now
ever so slightly going to be a weakness
we continue now with b4 the knight comes
back to c7
of course black is not really interested
in playing a takes b4
in fixing blacks or fixing white's
weakness so we get knight c7 instead
a trait of the rooks a trait of these
pawns
and white actually wins the pawn on b7
but in exchange black of course wins
this pawn
on c3 and now we actually see bishop d7
is kind of a funny move
perhaps highlighting how ineffective
this bishop on h3
actually was and now you might expect
the game to steer towards the draw such
reduced material
on the board each side has a past pawn
but in all likelihood they're just going
to be traded off for each other
unless something happens
and then the game is just kind of a dead
draw so
my question for you is with the black
pieces here
how do you create any kind of winning
chances
with nepo with black as nepo
has wong how ever played the fantasy
variation since he's such a wizard
um probably i can only hope i can only
hope
but his magic not enough not enough this
game
check the king and push the pawn rey i
don't
know if that's going to be enough here
so
what nepo does is essentially the
principle
of two weaknesses so we've all heard
this principle before
and it comes in many different forms in
this case rather than
two weaknesses i like to phrase it as
you know having
two kinds of threats on the board
so in this case threat number one is
going to be yon's
d-pawn yan wants to you know use this
pawn
to kind of give the white pieces
problems and try and you know threaten
to promote it
but the second weakness or second form
of threat
is kind of difficult to identify at this
point
right because white is of course going
to be trying to win this pawn
and so what yan comes up with here is to
attack
the white king and this turns out to be
more effective than you might expect
with so few pieces on the board um
in this case i white played rook to e7
and we get rook c2 check king g1 and yes
black does push the pawn so we have sort
of our first threat
but after rook d7 knight f5 it's pretty
clear that this pawn is
not going to make it too much further
white is pretty effectively you know
attacking it from behind
we see a5 and now rook a2
so black coming after this piece as well
uh rook a7
king f6 now a6 and
uh actually already yawn has sort of let
something slip but uh well we'll circle
back to that idea
in just a moment so a6 and
now jan comes up with a way to attack
the white king so it's a little bit more
clear
with the pieces positioned where they
are but how do you make any kind of
threat
to the white king in this position
how do you make any kind of threat from
here
and yeah chess king has the right idea
you need to include
another attacker the rook alone is not
going to be enough
this knight for the moment is actually
doing a reasonable job
of keeping white or black's knight from
interfering a little bit
uh interfering too much so jan brings in
the age
pawn push harry get him to h3 and all of
a sudden
checkmating threats are going to appear
with this king
lacking squares on the second rank
um wong hao does not panic though comes
up with rook a8
we see h3 now and now
a7 is a crucial crucial idea by
wang hao without this idea white would
actually just be dead lost and that's
why
um jan perhaps missed an opportunity a
little bit earlier
because now you do not
have the winning idea of playing
rook to g2 and
the winning idea which i'm actually
going to present as a puzzle here but
you don't have this idea
because this pawn is on a7 we'll talk
about that a little bit more
so with the king on g7 the uh
quote-unquote winning idea that jan
missed was to play
h4 immediately and this one tempo is
actually quite important
because if we follow down the same line
with rook a8
now all of a sudden after rook g2 king
h1
it is black to move and win in this
position i wonder if the chat room
can find it can the chat room find the
stunning win
from this position
knight takes knight push pawn it's
obvious
i wonder how obvious it is rey how
obvious is it
so i assume ray means 93 which is not
quite knight takes knight but then
knight takes knight would have to be
played
and i'm gonna push my pawn with white
and oof
if you push this pawn with black what if
i go rook to e8 what would happen then
you cannot queen and white's queening as
well
so it's not so simple as pushing the
pawn forever
knight g3 isn't quite gonna do that we
can just take with
the pawn and yeah your pawns are a
little bit scary
but white's pawn is scary as well don't
forget white has
some ideas as well
um chess king says rick gate wins on the
spot well
i think king f6 might be legal there and
then the game would continue
in the chat room it's now fighting
amongst themselves always
a sad day when the chat begins the
infighting
so the correct idea does turn out to be
knight e3 in this position
but the point now is that after takes
say
a7 we can simply move the rook
to a2 and now we are stopping rook g8
by defending the a8 square and there's
simply no way
to stop back rank mate so we're not
making a queen here but we're simply
checkmating white and it does turn out
that e2
is in fact a winning move here as well
although it does get a little bit
trickier
the idea is to play rook f2 afterwards
with the same
back rank mating idea and meeting rook
g8 check with king to f6
so you're not getting uh checked with a8
so this idea would have been great but
yan decided to play king f6 first
and now it turns out that white is just
in time with this
a7 move because now if we try to do the
same thing
um wait to move and draw here is another
interesting puzzle go ahead and pause if
you want to try to figure this one out
but of course the move is not knight
takes night when we lose to the same
idea
but actually rook to h8 and the point
now
is that we are preventing ourselves from
getting
checkmated so black now has to find the
move
knight to d1 going for a different
checkmate
but of course white is just in time to
take the h3
pawn and give himself a flight square
after that we see rook a2
and we are in fact going to have a drawn
position um complicated stuff
um so instead we see yon play king to e7
uh trying to keep the game going with
something else
wang now plays g4 and that's uh sort of
a move
that is faltering at i wouldn't say the
last step
but faltering after you know
successively avoiding
quite a dangerous dangerous trap by
bringing this pawn to a
a7 um and that tends to be something
that happens quite often in games to be
honest is
you feel like you successfully avoided
your opponent's devious devious trick
and then you end up sort of weakening
your position the turn after
so the danger is never gone in chess
unfortunately the danger's never gone
it turns out that the way to equalize
with white here is the
pretty crazy move knight to d2 this
knight is just in a bad
bad way on f1 hampering this king's
flight squares
and you need to improve it of course
this isn't capturable
due to check and queen but instead
wong hao plays g4 and just for example
of how this might go
something like knight e3 we're going to
bring this knight to e4 now
and these scary ideas of checkmate are a
little bit less scary
when our knight is so actively placed
right
by the way this isn't a checkmating
threat either
we're still just queening because our
knight covers the square now
so missed his chance to get active with
the knight instead we see g4
and now rook b8 actually gives up the
pawn
but wong hao is still fighting for the
draw manages to capture this pawn back
and despite all of yon's efforts
um black has once again
not been able to break down white's
defenses and wong hao
did navigate his way to a drum position
and then once again
after you know fixing his position he
unfortunately plays another move that is
perhaps a little bit
um inaccurate due to probably time
pressure
you know dodging so many traps takes
time and i think wong hao was quite low
on time at this point in the game
so it turns out that the best way to
sort of end the game
is sort of some some strange ideas here
rook d8 check would have been one way
if king e7 you bring the rook to h8 and
pick up this pawn
so king g7 instead and then you play
simply rook to e8
and you watch for these squares that the
knight is threatening to jump to
and if something like rook to f2 you
activate your rook
let's say knight d6 and now rook e3 and
you're just barely
holding everything together but you are
in fact holding it together
instead wong hao plays rook to c3 and
this turns out to be the wrong way to
try to defend
and we're gonna see here that yan
successfully breaks down
uh white's position we get knight b2 we
do see rook c8 check
and rook d3 with a similar idea but this
one doesn't work quite as well
after rook f2 no way to attack this
knight
and so there's no way to bring this rook
to the third rank
king g1 rook takes f3
now knight e4 rookie 3 is played the
knight comes back to g3
and this turns out to be the last missed
drawing attempt
for for wong hao after knight g3
wong hao actually immediately resigned
after rook to a3
it might not be obvious why at first
glance
but it turns out that this pawn on g4 is
simply indefensible and once this pawn
falls
the game really is going to be over
and we'll just take a quick look at that
for example if you play g5
we're going to simply bring this knight
back to e6
and eventually maneuver our rook over to
attack this pawn
and this is just going to be dead dead
lost
one last look though at wanghau's missed
drawing attempt
knight d6 would have been a much better
way to try and stay in the game
with white here and the point being
you're now actively seeking counter play
against f7
and this might be enough to prevent
black from taking your g4 pawn
all that being said though knight g3
rook a3 played in the game
and wong hao resigned perhaps a little
bit early but the guy did have two more
games to go left in the tournament
and at this point black is simply
winning
due to this idea of winning the pawn on
g4
so those were two of my favorite games
from the candidates i didn't get
to go over fan of the show anish geary's
game against fabi
uh maybe we'll save that one for next
week
but uh once again wong hao retiring
um you hate to see it but hopefully he
does
you know study up on his magic abilities
and congratulations once again to yon
on an excellent tournament uh and i'm
looking forward to see his match
against magnus carlson this
year later this year i think i don't
know we'll have to check i think it's
november but
i could be wrong anyways those of you
watching live please stay tuned we have
a lecture by sabina which should be
going live momentarily
go check it out and as always let me
know in the comments what you thought
that's it for me here tonight as always
thank you for watching and i will see
you next time
[Music]
you